très lu ce soir donc avec un peu plus de
51 % des voix il avait une autre liste
de gauche avec vous dans cette
triangulaire pour cette élection 2014
oui bonsoir
votre réaction à cette élection
écoutez il ya d'abord beaucoup de
satisfaction pour l'équipe qui est
autour de moi avec une réélection au
delà de ce que l'on pouvait espérer
parce que dans une triangulaire
finalement c'est compliqué toujours dans
ce genre de situation finalement la
liste que j'emmène qui est une liste
parti socialiste mais également quelque
peu ouverte et bien finalement nous
faisons un résultat qui est vrai à peu
près identique à celui de 2008 question
de l'ignoble l'es2 mini-club bonsoir on
sait que gueugnon c'est une base
électorale importante pour la gauche est
ce que vous dans cette campagne vous
confirmer ce qu'on a entendu par un
certain nombre de candidats c'est-à-dire
l'idée d'une sanction ou est ce que vous
faites partie de ceux qui disent mais
finalement nous le disait pas pendant la
campagne
nous n'avons pas ressenti cet élément de
politique nationale sur le plan local
nous avons fait une campagne qui étaient
dirigés en direction de la population
locale ce contrat d'avenir que j'avais
proposée d'ailleurs aux gagnants des
réunionnais a obtenu la majorité donc
sensiblement accepté validé par la
population et dans le même temps on sent
bien tout autour de nous que finalement
le contexte national a pesé